when it comes to certain fundamental
properties of nature such as the time is
not absolute and then at the subatomic
level that particles
take on a wavy dualistic character and
and a particle can be in several places
at once
those behaviors of nature uh contradict
our common experience
so the senses
uh when you get to very high speeds
relative speeds or very small sizes our
senses give us an inaccurate
Intuition or understanding of nature
any sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from Magic it's our
guest today on the into the impossible
podcast a man who on his last episode I
called him uh astronomy's Tolstoy he
didn't object uh maybe he didn't watch
the episode but um I really believe it
Alan I've been in love with your books
and and your way of thinking for 30 plus
years now since um since Einstein's
dreams and and actually no that's a lot
before that your best book your the book
that's changed my life
more than any book perhaps that I've
read of yours or maybe any others it's a
page Turner it's called the problem book
in relativity and gravitation and it
came out uh in when I was in grad school
or just before I started grad school I
think
um and it's in multiple print things it
is one of the best books ever written uh
I actually just saw Bill press recently
uh uh who is their co-author he's a
great guy I'm going to send him this
interview when we're done
um and uh Alan Lightman uh thank you for
joining us today on the into the
impossible podcast for your second
appearance thank you Brian it's great to
be on your program I love your books and
there's no difference no change in my
opinion after this wonderful new book
that uh you your folks were kind enough
to send to me in both of um written
printed hard copy in PDF and in audio
format and I loved all three I read all
three versions it's a lovingly and
Tenderly Illustrated with great pictures
of guys that look like this and and
other characters we're going to talk
about including my hero Galileo Galilei
uh and even sir Roger Penrose where I
will reconnect to the book I just
mentioned a problem book in gravity and
relativity so stay tuned for that we're
talking today is St Patrick's Day now
you're in the city of that's most
closely associated with this phenomena
of St Patrick's Day as I remember it uh
which is Boston Massachusetts just
outside slightly
and I have a connection to this day in
Boston because eight years ago I can't
believe it uh my team and I announced
the uh Discovery the nominal discovery
of the uh Cosmic microwave background
inflationary B mode polarization so
actually it was uh it was nine years ago
I mistweeted today I sent out a tweet
I'm gonna correct my own tweet uh but
the discovery was announced and it
heralded a new way of thinking about the
universe and that the Universe began not
only with a with a big bang not only
with an inflationary Epoch but according
to your colleague Max tegmark it was uh
unequivocal evidence for the Multiverse
which makes an appearance well I totally
disagree with that conclusion
as I thought you would so this wonderful
new book is called the Transcendent
Brian oh brain sorry I always get that
make my mom says she she named me that
uh specifically so that people would
make that mistake and actually we have
an interview that'll probably be out yes
it will be out by the time you're
watching this video with Alan and it's
by my with my colleague Allison motri
who is growing organoids brain organoids
in outer space on the International
Space Station and we're going to get to
that in this conversation and and your
thoughts on the future of brain
technology of human mind a machine
interfacing uh with uh folks like um
like Elon musk's neural link et cetera
and your colleague uh Noam Chomsky who
I've spoken to on the podcast before
but the reason I bring this up is
because Allison uh when he was on the
podcast we were coordinating and he
wrote me and he called me brain and I
just thought it was so funny because
he's a brain scientist so I've got an
official recognition that a brain
scientist thinks that I actually have a
brain uh this book is an incredible tour
to force and it's very much unlike your
other books and first thing I want to
ask you is I ask all my uh esteemed
guests I don't know if I asked you this
two years ago when I interviewed you uh
for the first time uh but we've we've
started a new segment on the podcast and
it's called Uh judging books by their
covers
so you're never supposed to judge a book
by their cover but what other Bayesian
priors do you have so the way I do it is
I ask the author to describe the cover
illustration the title and the subtitle
and what went into it and most of the
time I said my publisher forced me to do
it but I don't think they can have that
much leverage over uh intellect like you
so Alan please help us judge this
wonderful book by its cover
well I can talk about the title first
the subtitle spirituality in the age of
science sort of nails the subject matter
and the the main title the Transcendent
brain
is supposed to be a little bit more
poetic and metaphorical
but just uh suggests that the brain is
capable of
really amazing
phenomena and experiences the image on
the cover
uh I don't know what to say about that
uh that that was chosen by the the
publisher that I'm not at all unhappy
with that image but um
so be it
and the subtitle is uh spirituality in
the age of science so those are two
words that don't usually go harmoniously
together so
why was that was that a hurdle to get
past your uh your editors and uh
publisher no uh I've been writing about
this subject for some years uh this book
was intended to be sort of a
codification of what I've been writing
about before so my my editor
uh at random house uh was willing to go
with me on that Journey uh to put
spirituality next to science because he
understands the the way that I mean that
and uh my view of spirituality
is such that uh the two that is
completely consistent with the
scientific view of the world so he he
understands that very good so this book
has so much in it and uh I want to take
it from the standpoint of uh sort of
Steel Manning an opposite perspective
that I have uh I've mentioned to you
last time that I'm a I'm a practicing
Jew I'm not an orthodox Jew but I uh
attend synagogue and Temple
um I learn Hebrew I read the Old
Testament the Torah the Bible and the
original Hebrew and can get my way
around the talmud and Aramaic and um uh
and I'm often you know kind of chastised
by that we've had on the some of the
militant atheists well we haven't hunt
on the new atheists that you talk about
the most and you in fact had a a very
very intense Skirmish with it's
described at the end of the book with
Richard Dawkins but Richard Dawkins
wrote the forward to my one of my
previous guests uh who is a scholar at
MIT at one time Lawrence Krauss and he
wrote uh a forward to the the universe
from nothing book and he called it uh
basically the cosmological equivalent of
On the Origin of Species which I even
think
um I even think that Lawrence was
embarrassed by but nevertheless
um when I had Lauren's on I was sort of
struck and I've been on his podcast as
well I've been struck by how little the
scientific Community understands or even
appreciates about religion not only you
know obviously not from a believer's
perspective but are you you know kind of
um surprised by how little someone like
a Dawkins or for example Lawrence Krauss
did not know the origin and he's a Jew I
mean he was born Jewish and he's and
he's not not practicing but obviously
not but he had a bar mitzvah which I
didn't have and and so he he's educated
I asked him Lawrence you know the
meaning of the word Israel in the Jewish
language do you know the meaning of the
word Jew in Hebrew which is the language
of Judaism no he didn't know anything
and so I was struck and I told him this
I'm like Lawrence you know you've got a
great mind
but you're accepting the word of a 13
year old and you're just taking that
word he's like which 13 year old I said
you when you were 13 you gave up on ever
studying religion again as most Jewish
boys do and I know you're born Jewish
too but you're I don't believe you're
practicing what do you make of the of
the level of knowledge and rigor that
scientists approach or grapple with the
question of religion is it sufficient
are you asking me yeah I'm asking you
yeah sorry the long-winded question yes
uh
well
I think everybody should
not not just scientists but everybody
should know about the history of
religion and the meaning of religion I
mean of course there are many religions
you know Hinduism Buddhism Judaism
Christianity Islam
I think that everybody should have an
understanding some understanding of
those religions and their Origins and
a little bit about their cultural
history because
uh religion and science are the two
greatest forces that have shaped our
civilization
in my opinion and so if you don't
understand
the the history of religion and the the
the the the cultural significance of
religion then you really have a big gap
in your understanding of who we are and
who our society is
so that's my view uh I don't know
whether scientists or any more ignorant
of religion than than other people
but I do think we should all understand
religion
um and I think that you're that you
asked about you said that Lawrence
Krauss didn't know the meaning of the
word Israel doesn't it mean something
like uh grappling with God or yeah it
means uh it means wrestling or fighting
with God against God meaning yeah and in
contradistinction I should point out to
Islam which means submission to God and
I feel like people like and I told
Lawrence I said you're actually an
Israelite because you for all the you
know vitriol that you and and Richard
Dawkins kind of espouse towards uh
religious practitioners you nevertheless
are wrestling with God on a daily basis
yeah well I don't think that that my
interpretation of that wrestling with
God is Not That You Are
uh
necessarily fighting or or denying the
existence of God but that you are
working you're trying to understand
God's place in the cosmos uh just you
know as as the talmud as you mentioned
has has these dialogues and
conversations that we're trying to
understand
so that's my interpretation of that
phrase yeah I think you know the
beauties of a religion that is open to
questioning and and yes uh is is is that
and the basis of the religion is really
this kind of uh struggle and and and
um you know and and kind of in contrast
as I say it's it's in contradistinction
to other religions that view it as a
higher motive to have belief in the case
of Christianity and just pure faith and
or Islam which has you know the
submission to God as its catechism or
its main pillar of faith I pat on the
podcast my very first guest was a near
and dear friend I was Freeman Dyson and
I love Freeman and he used to spend his
Summers uh his Winters out here because
I guess Princeton New Jersey isn't the
greatest place to do one's time in the
middle of winter La Jolla is pretty nice
they come over and we talk and he was
the first guest in the podcast I said I
asked him in that podcast I said Freeman
you call yourself an agnostic uh but
what does that mean uh because it seems
to me I asked him do you go to uh do you
go to church on Sunday no I don't do
that do you read the scriptures do you
and he had won the Templeton prize and
he had been kind of embarrassed by that
in fact he told Martin Reese uh we
talked about this on the podcast I did
with Martin in October he said Martin
I'm so glad you won the Templeton prize
because now there's someone who deserves
it even less than I did uh Hey friends
just a quick request while you're
enjoying this video to leave a thumbs up
my thumb's a little bit preoccupied with
all Carlton again over here but I hope
yours is free enough to leave a like it
really helps me with the algorithm and
for extra credit homework assignment
leave a comment down below what you're
enjoying about this video now back to
the show
but Freeman yeah is such a mischievous
my is the title of his biography is uh
science Rebel a rebel of science so
anyway I said I said Freeman how would
someone intelligent alien looking at you
and looking at Richard Dawkins how would
they distinguish between the two of you
you both don't go to the same church and
you both don't study this so how do you
define this notion of spiritual but not
religious what does that mean and how do
you and how do you I'm a behaviorist so
how do you instantiate that in your life
yeah
well I think an alien could all they
would need to do is is to learn uh the
English language which I think they
could do in five minutes and then and
read read the articles and books that
those people have written and could see
a very clear difference between them
so um when when you you I take it you
practice more of a Buddhist per
tradition or do you have a deal I'm I'm
I'm I'm Jewish yeah like you and we we
do
uh observe
the Jewish holidays
but but I also uh
have a lot of admiration for Buddhism
I don't believe in rebirth which is part
of Buddhism uh but I do like many of the
tenets of Buddhism such as
being present in the moment and trying
to detach the ego from things that we do
and the temporary nature of existence uh
all of that is something I I subscribe
to mm-hmm
when we spoke last we spoke a lot about
Einstein and um obviously for Einstein's
dreams and it's just you know uh it's
it's one of the books I recommend most
of the people when I'm asked to give a
book recommendation of the price 1000
books I've had the chance to read over
the course of my life and uh one you
know obviously Einstein is the main
character and I've I've really kind of
two questions about Einstein he doesn't
really appear very much in this book
he's in there and we'll get to kind of
some of the aspects in which
um you connect to him but but in the uh
conception of him as a man of Faith or
perhaps an atheist it seems his
ambiguity spread like you know a
Schrodinger cat like State you know he
he was maybe purposely ambiguous it was
he religious was he not what's your take
and and do we make too much of like
trying to ape Our Heroes and emulate
them what was Einstein's take on
spirituality if if not religion well we
actually know what his take is because a
journalist asked him that uh it was I
think it was around 1933
um
you know point blank are you an atheist
and Einstein said no I'm not an atheist
um and and then he he said I I think
that the question
being the existence or non-existence of
God is is too big a question for our
little Minds
and then he went on to elaborate a
little bit
um
he said that
that I view
our connection to the cosmos
as a a child who walks into a huge
Library
a very large Library
and looks around and sees lots and lots
of books written in foreign tongues
and knows that that somebody wrote those
books
but they don't know who and they can't
read them
uh I mean and during his lifetime
Einstein tossed off various you know
flip comments like God doesn't play dice
and things like that
I don't think that those comments
represented his real religious views but
I do think that this answer to this
journalist in 1933 did represent
his actual views
and we hear about you know his famous
quote about kind of the spinozan god the
god of of Spinoza who you know kind of
is Manifest in the unity of all things
and it's not personal impersonal yeah so
that not intervening that still leaves
open I mean in Judaism not to give a
theology lecture but you know God has
really two main purposes to start the
universe which is you know our domain
and cosmology perhaps but then to be a
personal God right not to be the unmoved
Mover of Aristotle
Etc
um so I want to Pivot from Einstein to
an earlier uh generation and that was um
and that was the man that Einstein
called uh one of the greatest
contributors to Western civilization
essentially uh and that was Galileo and
I actually had the honor with your
fellow MIT colleague Frank wilcheck to
record the first ever audiobook by
Galileo and it's the dialogue the
dialogue on two World Systems which is
the Copernicus and the Aristotelian uh
kind of doing battle and um and Frank
wilcheck narrated The introduction by
Albert Einstein to this book
um and I read the voice of one of the
characters Carlo ravelli read another
one and uh I was really struck by the
kind of visceral nature that I that
Galileo had and he was greatly admired
by Einstein obviously and he talked
about the visual kind of impression and
you show in the book this this famous
woodcut from cedarius nunchius and you
also show a picture of his telescope and
you actually went there and I went to
archetree uh just a few years just a few
months ago I was in his uh his prison I
don't know if he actually went to his
his final uh imprisonment place but no I
didn't see that uh but you talk about
um the the fact that looking at the moon
which was previously thought to be uh to
be smooth perfect crystalline he said
anyone would then understand Galileo set
with the certainty of the senses that
the Moon is by no means endowed with a
smooth and Polished surface but is rough
and uneven and then you talk about a
letter in 1812 to to an Italian
scientist and of course he was wrapped
up in religion he was very deeply
religious this canopy speaks of the next
kind of section I want to get into which
is the the interface between the
physical and the spiritual and a lot of
that is is appreciated via the sense of
sight and uh the Torah is very skeptical
about the the eyes uh the Shema which is
like the catechism the Our father of
Judaism says do not stray after your
eyes they cause you to to yourself
to be a prostitute to your eyes
um what to what you know extent should
we trust the visual Sensations the
appreciation as a way that Galileo did
to prove things whether scientific or
spiritual
well of course one thing that we've
learned from modern science which you
know as well as I do is that the 20th
century
science and especially 20th century
physics has shown us that our senses
lead us astray
when it comes to certain fundamental
properties of nature such as the time is
not absolute
and then at the subatomic level that
particles
take on a wavy dualistic character and
and a particle can be in several places
at once
uh those
behaviors of nature uh contradict our
common experience
so
the senses
uh when you get to very high speeds
relative speeds or very small sizes our
senses give us uh an inaccurate uh
Intuition or understanding of nature
uh in terms of spirituality
well it's a great
it's a great question because
the experiences that I
call spiritual
for example
uh looking up at this a starry night and
feeling connected to the cosmos
or uh
making eye contact with the wild animal
or feeling connected to Nature
those experiences May originate with the
senses
But ultimately they are mental
experiences
and so
when you say well yes whether we should
trust our senses
um I think that in the physical world
that we can trust our senses for most
things that that we experience
uh in daily life
uh
and the spiritual world I think that the
the essence of the experiences are not
sensory
that they are mental and that the senses
may be triggers
to the feelings that we call spiritual
feelings but but ultimately it's not
about the senses
a new Explorer in the next chapter uh
you start or in a later chapter you
start to encounter a man that I briefly
knew at Caltech uh Christoph uh
who's now I believe up in Washington
Seattle area
um and you and you kind of get into the
real application of modern scientific
tools and apparatus in terms of the
understanding of Consciousness and I've
had I haven't had him on I'm hoping to
get him on eventually the problem is he
wrote his book so long ago it's it's not
likely he's going to get that patented
Keating bump uh that you'll surely enjoy
uh and they will pay for another another
beach house in Maine someday for you
Alan you can send me an invitation but
you you talk about uh kind of the
computational aspects of the mind and I
wonder you know of the different
perspectives that are explored of the
four or five major perspectives that you
explore is is one more convincing or
less convincing we'll get to you know
some some
um some comments by past guests
um Donald Hoffman and and Roger Penrose
in just a bit but what was Cox like when
you when you look at the Modern
application and the breakthroughs that
they've had I still come away feeling
like we still don't know what it's like
to be a bat we you know we saw and I've
had on um uh
um you know uh now I'm blanking on his
name at uh nyu's uh the progenitor David
Chalmers I've had him on yeah we did an
episode it's still the hard problem so I
mean what it doesn't seem to be getting
any easier I wonder you know is it just
too hard this computer on our shoulders
if it is a computer which I don't think
it is and Penrose doesn't think it is
um will we ever be able to answer the
most basic questions and to the extent
we can't answer what is it like to be a
bat say what uh what hope is there to
understand the deeper origins of
Consciousness yeah well it's a wonderful
question
and I agree with you that we're a long
way from understanding how Consciousness
emerges from the brain
but I think that it's it's perfectly
reasonable to take the position
that that Consciousness and all of our
mental Sensations Consciousness
according being the fundamental mental
sensation
is perfectly reasonable to take the
point of view that all of those mental
experiences
ultimately originate in the material
neurons in the brain
even if
we cannot fill in all the blanks to get
from those material neurons to the
really incredible extraordinary unique
sensation of consciousness
um
we can still believe that that its
origin is material
even though we can't fill in all the
blanks
to say how that gets to this incredible
first person subjective experience we
call Consciousness I totally agree that
we don't know what it feels like to be a
bat
computer most people in AI including
Chris
believe
that
that any finite list of attributes that
you associate with Consciousness any
finite list of manifestations of
Consciousness and you say this is the
the sign of Consciousness that we will
someday be able to build a computer that
checks all the box boxes
but whether or not we will know that
that entity is conscious or not
that's a different question because to
know that you have to really know what
it feels like to be a computer
we don't know what it feels like to be a
dolphin or what it feels like to be a
crow and surely Consciousness whatever
it is it's a graded phenomena you know
an amoeba is almost certainly not
conscious but uh a crow and a dolphin
have exhibited behavior that we
associate with Consciousness they have
some level of Consciousness not not
equal to humans perhaps
but even with those other animals you
know the Dolphins and crows we don't
know what it feels like to be a dolphin
or a crow right or um you know it's
conceivable to me that someday in the
distant future we may understand brain
science well enough
that we can implant a chip in our brain
that somehow connects our neurons to the
neurons of a dolphin or a crow it's it
seems that in principle that that's not
ruled out
and if that's ever possible then we may
begin to start begin to know what it
feels like to be a dolphin or a crow
and now when I use that as a springboard
to try on you uh a thought experiment a
gedonkan experiment as our good friend
Albert would say I'm looking for my
finger puppet you know someday I'll have
a finger puppet of you somewhere oh no
this is not him this is uh this is
Newton uh this is Galileo so we were
talking about Galileo he'll have to
stand in for Einstein uh the old one um
so Einstein said as happy as thought can
you it's like when I talk to David
Chalmers I said I have to ask you to
define the hard problem because it would
be like a hat on Abba another famous uh
uh product of Australia where David
Chalmers is from I said it'll be like I
have Abba on the podcast and I don't ask
him to sing dancing queen so I said
David Define the hard problem I can't
resist you to Define uh for our to
remind my audience what Einstein called
his happiest thought
well I I think that he meant by that his
his happiest thought was to to realize
that that gravity is equivalent to
acceleration am I right about that yeah
and he envisioned the Duncan experiment
was that if he was in free fall he'd
experience no gravitational acceleration
so I want to use that to Pivot to what
you just said we can't know what it's
like to be Einstein we can't know it but
can a computer a have a happiest thought
what does that even mean and B can
experience a thought based on a thought
experiment based on a visceral sensation
of free fall I think it's totally
impossible but I'm curious what you
might say
well of course
a computer could have sensory input
I mean you could in fact in in the uh
public television series that I was
involved with I have a conversation with
with an advanced Android and she has
photo cells
where she can see me
she she has uh earphones where she can
hear me and she can interpret
those sounds in terms of language which
then reflect back on her vast database
so I think that we can build a computer
that has sensory input
um into the computer
um
what was the uh
happiness yeah well first of all
you have to Define what thinking is
to answer that question and
we could Define thinking as taking
certain information is in input and then
having some output
and if you define thinking in that way
or some way that's equivalent to that
certainly
we can build a computer that can think I
mean it it may be more complicated than
that
um
happiness well that's you know I'm I'm
deconstructing your your statement
happiest thoughts so first we talked
about thinking now we talk about happy
which is an emotion
and could a computer have an emotional
state yes
that seems to me a harder one than
whether it can think
um
I mean you could probably put artificial
tear ducts on a computer and make it cry
ing a robotic arm and it could shake its
fist at you
out of anger uh but but I don't know
whether
we will be able to build a computer that
that truly has emotions um that's that's
a tough one yeah
yeah I I agree it seems almost
impossible and and pivoting to from one
Nobel Prize winner to another which is
Sir Roger Penrose who's talked about
quite quite a good deal and and you know
respectful and and quite interesting
terms and you know his uh collaboration
with Stuart hammeroff emerged from his
book uh the emperor's new mind which was
actually the first popular science book
I ever read and uh he honored Me by
putting uh his name on this book and
behind me my losing Nobel prize book
endorsed that book a long time ago but
the the reason that that book made such
an impact on me is because it really
portrayed the future as being incredibly
exciting and having first defining what
computation is and then ultimately being
ambiguous and and uncertain as to
whether or not at that point computation
was what was really the essence of
Consciousness and later with hammeroff
uh who I've interviewed both of them and
we'll have links to those interviews
above
um I've entered in the the two of them
and you know they really maintain that
not only is consciousness not a not a
computational or amenable to to Pure
computation via basically an abstract
analogy from girdles incompleteness
theorem which you know we can refer
people to my chats with him but but that
Consciousness is actually instantiated
via some gravitational interaction with
uh this classical grenomenon so it's not
even a Quantum it has to do with the
wild curve vial curvature Etc so I'm
going to ask you to hearken back to that
first book problem book on gravity and
general relative
um what do you make of their Theory
microtubules are quantum phenomena that
interact with the classical
gravitational field what is I I don't I
don't believe it for one minute why is
that and and I think that it was it was
roundly dismissed by by neuroscientists
that that book and his thesis
um
well Roger Penrose of course understands
all of physics much more than I do
including quantum physics
but I'll just say the elementary thing
that the the the
fundamental
unit of action in the brain is the
neuron
and of course we know that each neuron
is connected to between a thousand and
ten thousand other neurons
and the neuron is not a Quantum object
it's a macroscopic object even though we
can't see it with the naked eye it's
uh that a neuron has trillions and
trillions of atoms in it it's far
Beyond uh you know the realm where
quantum physics acts there's no such
thing as that you can't have
entanglement or coherence between
neighboring neurons because there's way
too much noise in the brain which would
destroy any kind of you know Global
entanglement or
coherence so so I think it's it's
absolutely
you know impossible that quantum physics
or GR
could play a role
in the brain so I I I I I I don't I mean
I'm first acknowledging that that Roger
Penrose knows a lot more physics than I
do I I just think that that's a crazy
idea
and
neuroscientists as I said roundly
dismissed it
uh so I don't know what else to say
about it I mean Penrose is a brilliant
guy and he's you know came up with
Brooke Penrose tiles and worked with
Hawking on general relativity and all
kinds of incredible discoveries but I
think he got into deep water on that
book yeah he he told me in person in the
first interview I ever did about five
years ago with him that you know when he
wrote the book he thought and he hoped
that he would get tons of letters
written letters back then 1989 from
young people saying oh I'm so excited
and turned me on to science and it did
for me but I didn't write him a letter
but he said no he just got all these
letters from old guys with con you know
their own theories of Consciousness and
computation but the one who is I guess
middle-aged at the time for 30 plus
years ago was was Stuart hammeroff was
an anesthesiologist who says you know
his greatest joy is you know turning off
Consciousness
um but uh but that's that's a topic for
another day Roger as you know one of his
books is uh called faith and fantasy in
physics and the fantasy part I don't
know if you've read that book uh it
revolves around the concept of
cosmological inflation
and cosmological inflation was pioneered
uh by your collaborator and friend next
door to you if I remember correctly or
not too far away Alan Guth who went
unconscious when I spoke there in 2016
at a colloquium but I I've heard he does
that not information he does that all
the time so you should you should it's
not personal
thank you Alan uh that salvages what's
left of my ego
um but um I have a question here from
another Pioneer who's closely related
not only to inflation but to the
inflationary Multiverse uh who's a big
fan of your work and uh his name is
Andrea Linde and I wrote him this week
to tell him he's coming on the podcast
in a few weeks uh and he agreed uh to uh
he agreed to come in the box but he's
great he sent me I asked him you know do
you have any thoughts about Alan uh and
his writing and his new book which he
hasn't seen but he's also mentioned in
your previous book which we talked about
uh last year and I'll have a link to
that uh awesome interview awesome guest
I don't know how good an interviewer I
am but but anyway um he writes Dear
Brian I like Alan and I respect him very
much he is great and he writes
beautifully I did not know about the new
book so I don't know what he says about
me but I've seen his article in the
Atlantic it is wonderful
um if I understand him correctly he
believes in spirituality but assumes
that it's possible only in the presence
of ordinary matter like proton atoms or
molecules this is an economic assumption
and in science we should always look for
the simplest most economical explanation
of everything however since some people
may have different assumptions in this
respect you may ask Alan if this is just
an assumption like a statement of faith
so that's the first question is this an
assumption this postulate that because
there's matter always present and
spirituality kind of runs on a is a
software layer that runs on the hardware
layer the it from bit
um can you comment on that is is this
just an assumption or can we actually
did you make this assumption basically
for Occam's razors uh purposes uh
certainly it's an assumption
um I mean all of science is an
assumption
you know we
uh science is is a uh
is is a continuing Endeavor to make
better and better approximations about
the behavior of the world
but we make certain assumptions in
science for example that the laws of
physics that we observe on Earth are the
same as the laws of physics and outer
space
the laws have a universality
uh we we assume that a cause and effect
relations
and
we we make the assumption
that there are no additional
forces or or
Essences or ethereal essences
beyond the the atoms and molecules and
energy that we observe and can quantify
we make that assumption you can't prove
that assumption
right I mean that's why we call it an
assumption right it's a lucretius you
know he's got a lot of citations to that
that paper right yeah so so we can't we
can't prove it
um just the same way that God that the
science can't prove whether God doesn't
exist and religion can't prove that God
does exist that these are
statements that we we
accept or reject on the basis of faith
and and science makes the the
fundamental Assumption of science I
think is that the universe is orderly
you know that it obeys laws and that in
principle that human beings will
eventually discover those laws or at
least very good approximations to those
laws
and so so yes I I think it's an
assumption and I I agree with with Andre
said
it's it's an economical assumption uh
but it is an assumption so here's a
follow-up question and he does this by
way of analogy he says before the
invention of general relativity everyone
believed the gravitational field only
appears in the presence of massive
bodies and this gravitational field does
not have any independent degrees of
freedom but it turned out this this
belief was incorrect In gr Juan may have
an evolving Universe without any
electrons and protons filled by an
oscillating gravitational field
gravitational waves having their own
degrees of freedom
thus space-time and gr is alive it's not
just a mathematical tool for describing
behavior of ordinary matter it has its
own degrees of freedom can involve
propagate even in the absence of matter
took 100 years and billions of dollars
since the invention of gr to observe
gravitational Waves by your colleague
and past guest uh Ray Vice and Barry
barish who's my co-author on my second
book uh uh into the impossible bicep
tries to find gravitational mind
experiments
which may have existence in the Big Bang
so the answers of my questions whether
it is possible at all with respect to
Consciousness the subject of This
Magnificent book of yours and
spirituality that we're just at the
beginning of the place that physicists
were at a hundred years ago with respect
to space time before Einstein and before
the billions of dollars were spent and
he has a link to the paper that he wrote
uh dedicated to John Wheeler 20 years
ago I'll send it to you later yeah go
ahead and go back before I answered that
question yes when Lindy says that that
the the gravity can exist without the
presence of matter
uh Einstein's theory and even his his
theory of special relativity which you
know very well is that matter and energy
have some equivalence
and a gravitational wave has energy in
it
so
when when the Lindy says can can can
grab it exist without the presence of
matter
um
it can exist without the presence of
matter or energy and a gravitational
wave has energy in it that's what makes
the the two mirrors on ligo you know
oscillate back and forth
[Music]
um
so the the question whether we are and
understanding Consciousness are we at
the same stage that physicists were a
hundred years ago or a scientists
um I don't I don't know whether it's a
hundred years ago but I certainly agree
that we're at an infant's stage you know
we're we're in our infancy of
understanding Consciousness we do know a
lot about the brain
um we know pretty much how neurons work
and
we know the how neurons send electricity
uh how electricity flows through
individual neurons we know how they they
communicate with each other with
chemicals
uh neurotransmitters
but when you put a hundred billion
neurons together each connected to 10 to
10 000 other neurons or even if you put
a thousand neurons together we can't
even simulate a thousand neurons
uh you get you get emergent phenomena
you get behavior of that system
that you can't predict on the basis of
individual neurons
and it it might be a very long time
before we understand
how that
right yeah qualitative Behavior comes
about so Philip Anderson you know coined
the term you know more is different only
in the 1950s and that launched the field
of you know condensed matter physics but
you know atoms and molecules have been
around for you know thousands of years
since secretions as we said
um turning to that kind of subjective
experience and you did mention you know
kind of this notion of of you know
perception another past guest on the
podcast Donald Hoffman who's also spoken
a lot about conscious you can tell I'm
very interested in concert I've had on
all these these great minds and and
brains and and your contribution was was
um not surprisingly influential on me
but it was not different enough uh for
your perspective is different enough to
say Hoffman's or even penrose's that I
thought it would be interesting to get
your take so he asserts that there is a
evolutionary that what we experience is
consciousness is basically evolutionary
low-pass filtering that we see reality
as sort of a dashboard where their icons
the icons of you know PowerPoint or you
know Microsoft Excel they look different
they represent different pointers and
and our neurons and and the emergence
comes about as a sense of perception
that's evolutionarily optimized to uh to
for our benefit uh in other words we're
conscious is is just another level of of
perception but there's nothing to say
that say an osprey which we'll talk a
lot about in just a minute but there's
nothing that an osprey couldn't actually
perceive and perhaps not even the the
electrons in the screen might also have
Consciousness so-called pan psychic pan
psychistic or pan psychism what do you
make of this that a Consciousness I hate
asking these double barrel questions but
we only have a few more minutes left
um double bear question is uh is is
consciousness an evolutionary phenomenon
which would seem to me that electron
couldn't be conscious because they don't
evolve
um uh let me just start with that and
then I'll pivot to uh selection of
course I'm not an evolutionary biologist
but I I do think it's very plausible
that conch business evolved and that if
you could go back to
prior to homo sapiens
go back you know several million years
that you might find uh this pre-human
some member of the homo genus
uh that that had a lower level of
Consciousness than what we have now so I
think that's very plausible that it
evolved
and then thinking about
um you know this this evolutionary uh
kind of experience that you know he
talks about while the taste of chocolate
in this book the case against reality
talks about how you know the taste of
chocolate might have evolved to imprints
such that it's really one in the same
like we experience red perhaps it's
different but every time I see red and
you see red it might be different but
but we agree that it's redness to us and
that the taste of chocolate is really
just the conscious experience there's no
absolute Taste of chocolate yeah yeah I
totally agree with that yeah so um you
know thinking of coffee and chocolate
you know that I'm having here with my
Irish uh you know Edition because it's
St Patrick's Day right on So You Gotta
Irish up the coffee for the professor
before I start to teach
um I thought a lot in this book about
about you know there are maybe
unintentionally a lot of judaic themes
that run through it and you know uh we
we've talked a little bit about that but
as I said you know one of the things
that Lawrence Krauss and and the other
you know self describe militant Athens
didn't know what does the word Jew mean
where does his name come from I think
it's very important I was having lunch
with a very good friend who's Persian
and I said uh where does the word Iran
come from what does it mean and I knew
it meant Aryan or it meant Aaron but but
what does that actually mean like Aryan
it's misused by by Germans obviously in
World War II but uh so we looked it up
we use chat GPT which I don't think
we're gonna have enough time I wanted to
talk a lot about the The Perils and
pitfalls of chat but I'll wait for your
next book which I assume you're writing
as we're talking right now I just love
it uh we'll do that another time but um
but we asked chat gbt what's the origin
of Aryan and we kept drilling down into
it and it comes out the meaning of it in
an Indo-European dialect of the meaning
of Aryan is noble men or free person in
other words Aryans are free people and
they should Endeavor in the Persians and
the Iranians they should Endeavor to be
free in Judaism the word Jew comes from
Yehuda which means hodea which means
gratitude
um you talk a lot I love that yeah you
talk a lot in this book so so that
Persians are on it I mean it's not a
mandate but you should at least like
think about it like we should be
knowable we should be free people and I
wish that the Iranian government would
practice more freedom especially for the
the women that are being subjugated so
violently there but anyways we're not
going to Virtue signal too much today
but but the point is
um you know who do you give gratitude to
you see an osprey
um I find a problem with with modern
scientists is that most experiences Lord
Rabbi sacks who passed away as Chief
Rabbi of the United Kingdom he said that
um it's natural when you have a
Transcendent Peak experience to want to
give gratitude uh you see the Grand
Canyon you see uh Concord Lake you see
an osprey swooping over your head
um you want to give gratitude it feels
so great and religious people have an
outlet who do you give gratitude to yeah
Osprey you know Evolution uh Darwin how
do you manifest that sense of gratitude
which is so inculcated in you personally
and in your spirit and in the essence of
spirituality as you define
I have above my desk
uh I know this is not Israel I don't
know whether you can oh yeah
yeah I see that oh I see uh right I have
above my desk a poster of about uh 20
people that I've known in my past
who have been influential
who have mentored me
some of them have passed away now
and every day I look up at that poster
and I look at all those faces and I
express my gratitude to those people
wow
that's amazing
so you know my take on Rabbi Sox's you
know statement is that we scientists and
and now that's very I mean that was just
I'm Blown Away by that sentiment out but
just in the interest of time so so the
the thing that I notice is that we as
scientists are when you saw the you know
moons of Jupiter where you saw a rainbow
you saw that Osprey you have a very deep
scientific knowledge beyond the average
person you know 10 Sigma but but then
that's fine and an average person can
experience Transcendence my child can
experience it uh but when we experience
it in Judaism there's actually blessings
like you see a rainbow you see a meteor
shower you give a blessing because it's
so overarching but when a scientist sees
you know sees something every single day
I believe they kind of get inured to the
sense like we we kind of lose track of
like we're studying the origin of the
universe we're made of matter and this
matter is comprehending how it came
about possibly and then we have all
these squabbles and
um isn't it isn't it just like
you get overwhelmed like I I get very
much overwhelmed and I find it can be
paralytic I feel like you can appreciate
Beauty so much my daughter's smile you
know I'm putting her to bed I'm like
she's not gonna be this age forever
she's not gonna want me in the bed with
her you know you know when she turns
five or whatever who knows how do you
how do you grapple with that can you
give my listener some advice about like
how do you how do you handle the
blessings just even if your life is crap
it's still pretty damn good how do you
handle the blessings of gratitude if you
don't have a director you know A Gift
Giver to give gratitude too
well I think that is
I mean it's a wonderful question and I
think that in general that none of us
Express gratitude enough
um and as a scientist and my witness of
a rainbow or
uh
a wild Osprey making eye contact my
scientific understanding of that does
not in the slightest diminish my awe
and I love the Buddhist idea of of
being present of of mindfulness
that that if we can uh
learn how to even if it's only a few
minutes a day just turn off our cell
phones turn off our computers and just
pay attention to the moment
and the moment is so beautiful I mean
we're so lucky to be alive
uh if you think of it you know out of
the trillions and trillions of sperm
cells and trillions of trillions of eggs
in your mother
the the one of them became you
and all of those other ones never became
a living being I mean just that fact
alone
uh life in the universe is incredibly
rare life and if you look at all the
matter in the universe
life that the fraction of matter in the
universe that's alive is is one
billionth of one billion it's like one
grain of sand on the Gobi Desert
so
when you think of those things
you realize how lucky and precious
life is and just keeping your eyes open
and being mindful for a few moments
that's what I recommend
and it's increasingly been shown to be
the case that from brain scientists you
know far more knowledgeable than I that
yeah it's giving gratitude in the
morning granting gratitude at night
bullet journaling however you like is uh
leads to pronounced Improvement in
mental health and well-being Alan the
last thing that we've added uh in the
last two years since you've been uh
gracing us while your presence on this
podcast uh are the four final questions
the final four existential questions not
unlike the final four of NCAA basketball
which I know the MIT beavers will be
playing the San Diego tritons and a
hotly contested battle we have I doubt
it so I asked my uh my audience these
questions I don't think I had time to
ask you we only have five minutes this
time I'm gonna ask you at least I'll see
how many we can get first one of the
existential questions has to do with
what you'll put in your ethical will
[Music]
which is in Hebrew called the Zava ah
these are sort of a template of not
Material wealth but spiritual or
intellectual or perhaps a wisdom will
what would you leave to your Offspring
not only biological but also ideological
like the hundreds of thousands of people
listening to this podcast
I don't think we can do better than the
Golden Rule do unto others that you
would have them do unto you
very good Richard Feynman uh said many
things including about Consciousness and
appreciation and gratitude he said uh in
Contra distinction to
um uh I think it was Walt Whitman maybe
or uh whoever wrote the poem I heard the
Learned astronomer who was dismayed that
the night had been turned to numbers he
said who am I is a man who cannot
appreciate the knowledge of Jupiter uh
just because I know he's made of
nitrogen uh meaning the planet Jupiter
rather than just looking anyway Feynman
was asked the question if in some
cataclysm all scientific knowledge were
to be destroyed and only one sentence
passed to the next generation of
creatures what statement would contain
the most information the fewest words
and this comes back to the hero of the
beginning of the story lucretius who
mentioned Adams I don't know what he
said Adam Adams that's right they're
whirling around anyway what would you
put
how would you answer the cataclysm
question what what single sentence most
best encapsulates maybe a little bit of
swagger for the for for Humanity to have
uh in perpetuity that we figured out
something truly tremendous about the
universe since since Feynman perhaps
foreign
the physical Universe had a beginning
very good very good into that you can
turn to a problem book in general
relativity and gravitation uh which is I
just love that book Alan I'm so glad you
wrote it well thank you uh and uh next
question third question
and I'm not calling I'm not meaning to
insult you although the interview is
almost over so I can get away with no uh
Sir Arthur C Clarke who is the namesake
of the center that I am the associate
director here of called the Arthur C
Clarke Center for human imagination
said when a distinguished but elderly
scientist says something is possible he
is almost certainly right but when he
says something is impossible he is very
probably wrong
[Music]
I want to ask you Alan what thing topic
you know conjecture have you been wrong
about
recently or in the past
conjecture have been wrong about not the
only scientifically it could be about
your own life like good or you know I've
been wrong about many things
uh
well let me let me think I mean I've
been wrong about so many things that
it's hard to think of one particular
thing to mention
um
I
think that I was
wrong and thinking uh my wife is a very
people-centered person
and
and she she lives in the moment she's
much better in her people relations than
I am and I think that when we first got
married I thought that I would
never be able to
change my ways
and and be more of the kind of person
that that she would be compatible with
and and I and we both have grown closer
to each other
uh in our in our mannerisms and our
Behavior so I was wrong about that and
I'm very happy that I was wrong about
that all right well we're gonna have to
send her a copy of this interview okay
Alan uh last time last question the
final one we have one minute left lastly
going back in time Arthur C Clarke said
the only way to discover the limits of
the possible is to venture a little way
past them into the impossible it's the
original name of my podcast right what
mysterious aspect of your life perplexed
you at age 20 or 30 and gave you the
courage in hindsight to perhaps give
yourself advice to that 20 year old to
give yourself the courage to go into the
impossible what advice would you give to
your 20 30 year old self
[Music]
what advice would I give to my 20 year
old self yes to give you that courage
um
well these are these are profound
questions and it's hard to quickly come
up with answers don't worry you've got
10 seconds all right okay right
foreign
I think I would tell myself that you can
fall in love with more than one person
ah wow and that could even be yeah with
a mind with a conscious mind or a
spiritual being a god well Alan uh we're
in love with your mind and your writing
and you're welcome back here anytime I'm
gonna pass the interview on to Andre
he's gonna come on I'm gonna ask you in
a few minutes or weeks or whatever
please send me a question for Andre that
would be a lovely touch Alan thank you
so much shabbat shalom and that's such a
pleasure thank you for your contribution
to our intellectual rapaciousness and
slaking our hardware for a little bit
you're you're a great intellect yourself
Brian and uh it's really a pleasure to
to have conversation with you I learned
a lot about talking to you thank you I
love it thank you Alan have a great day
thank you
[Music]